hello my name is Samuel each I do a Q&A
Sunday and what's gonna be happening
right now
you're in luck by the way because I'm
going to be answering questions from
last week's Q&A Sunday which is cool but
the reason you're in luck is because if
you ask a question right now in the
comments below
next Sunday I will be doing my best to
answer as many questions as I can from
you right now commenting so if you've
got a niggling burning question around
property investment tax mortgages the
economy making money colabello so let's
see what we had last week the questions
I've never done a Q&A so no video where
I'm looking through the questions
thinking these questions suck like you
guys I just all it and you questions I
can tell that you're a smart following
because of your awesome questions so
let's see what we've got
Lewis Clark Joel Barry
Craig I let's take some of these what
does Craig say Craig a command he says
hi Samuel since watching your videos and
attending the crash course last year
I've been buying properties using the
beat ar-ar-ar strategy boom good job man
I'm glad you came to the crash course
and I'll be shortly completing on my
fourth property purchase when we
financing our use interest only
mortgages to maximize cash flow and
leverage as I'm looking to grow my
portfolio smart at what stage in my
property journey would you advise to
consider switching them to a repayment
mortgage or would you just wait until
the latter end of my life and hope the
properties have greatly appreciated over
time and potentially sell off some in
order to then use the profits to clear
the debt on the others keep up the great
work
Craig firstly congratulations sounds
like you've been doing it right brrrr is
buy refurbish refinance pull your money
back and then you can keep buying lots
of properties that way
transy question would I stop paying down
the mortgages personally I probably
wouldn't now I can't advise you on what
to do because what you do with your
personal finances is obviously your
decision myself so for the first 10
years of investing in property I was
just interest only in just only interest
only and the reason for that is exactly
of you as you've said because if I'm
paying down the mortgages I'd rather
instead of using my money to pay off
mortgages I'd use that money to put down
on more deposits to then scale leverage
grow a bigger portfolio get more cash
flow benefit from more capital
appreciation for more houses so just
make sense
and even like very very wealthy people
like Robert Kiyosaki Grant Cardone like
day use interest only mortgages they're
not paying down their mortgages they're
still leveraging other people's money in
the bank's money so I think the answer
to your question is if you get to a
point where you don't want to continue
scaling if you're important you think
you know what I don't want any more
houses I don't want to scale my wealth
anymore then fare it off maybe start
paying down the mortgages for me in 2019
I did start paying off the mortgages I
paid off so many mortgages and I also
started lending money alone it's got a
bit lazy and I thought I'm happy now I
don't need more money and it's actually
Grant Cardone that called me out on this
in a in a private one-on-one mentoring
session and he was just like dude are
you over the hill now I was like I'm not
over the hill he was like well you
you're not scaling big anymore you kind
of slowed him down
I was thinking he's in his sixties I'm
still in my 20s like if he's still on
leveraging and scanning and growing and
I'm now thinking I've got enough houses
now when I start being met maybe my
mindset is wrong maybe I want to you
know I want I want to be as wealthy as I
can not just for me so I can have a lot
of wealth so I can impact more people so
for me are more about interest only and
then at the end of the term you can just
sell off some of the houses and pay off
some of the mortgages or renew or the
world is your oyster that's my personal
plan so I hope that helps thanks for you
great question good to see you kicking
ass come back to the crash course Craig
and let's celebrate lose Clark love the
content as usual I'm 15 so good to have
young people are on the channel I was
wondering what I should do now I've
saved up 10 thousand pounds in my
savings through my paper round
I live in Scotland thanks Lois Clark
respect man I did the same thing I
didn't quite mostly same up ten thousand
pound but while I was at school I had
several thousands of pounds but did 15
kangaroos and paper else whatever you do
you my friend are going to be successful
because to save up ten grand from paper
round's that means that your work ethic
is frigging through the roof you know so
and you respect money and you're
prepared to work so the limits I have no
doubt that you are going to be very
successful as long as you continue with
the work ethic continue with the work I
think but what you need to do now is you
need to start looking smart if you made
ten thousand
from paper else I don't know how many
papers you have to push through doors
just to make twenty pounds probably
quite a lot it's probably like a day's
worth of pushing you know it's a lot so
your work ethic is good what I would say
to you now Luis is now you need to start
working smart you're 15 years old he's
still very very young I would be I would
be wanting to get hands-on experience in
the property industry I'd want to be
saying right I want it I want to go and
work on a building site for six weeks I
want to go and hang out with some estate
agents and understand the property
market interest rates
I would I would start now working smart
and also instead of working hard for
money which you do at the moment which
is great start working hard for
knowledge
you know trading your time not for money
but trading your time for knowledge and
experience because I've got real high
hopes and I hope to see you as well at
crash course we're actually you come in
I think I don't if it's sold out yet but
we've come in to Edinburgh soon to do a
crash course so getting out - let's
forget Milan I'd love to meet you
respect Joe Barry so I've seen the BR
our strategy is very successful my
question is what mortgage would you get
all alone would it be a bridge loan or a
buy-to-let as I know when you read find
out see it will have to be by to let you
to it being rented out but what mortgage
do you get at the start okay so it's
both you're going to start with bridge
or cash you need to buy the house for
cash bridging finance is the same as
cash the seller will see it as cash
because you're not getting a mortgage
you're just getting a loan a short term
loan to buy the house when you're a cash
buyer you get discounts you can pay what
you want you buying it cash so you're
going to buy it cash or with a bridging
loan then you're going to push the value
up you're going to force the value up on
the house and then you're going to
refinance it on a standard buy to let
mortgage depending on the property if
it's like a HMO you might need an HMO
more victory it's just a standard buy to
let buy to let mortgage you're going to
refine that's it and then you're going
to pay off the bridging loan or pay
yourself back the cash that you put down
and if you do it right you put all of
your money out and then you just recycle
keep buying more houses and leveraging
your money so you can use the same
amount of money over and over and over
and that's how you strategize it
hope that helps Joe thanks to your great
question what else do we have is that
dis dare Vic
cool man he sounds like a strong man a
strong man he said heist I'm your part
from the deal itself what are the most
important things to have in check when
working with a possible angel investor
okay so an angel investor means someone
that's going to finance your deal so an
individual or an investor that's gonna
say hey look the deal was good I'll back
it so is that you've said that apart
from the deal itself I'm glad you said
that because the deal itself is the most
important part okay so if you want to
get an angel investor I would say get a
good deal you've got to have confidence
if you have confidence if you're like
look this is the deal it's good and I'm
good that's all so that's really
important and then thirdly I would say
maybe get some third-party credibility
checks on it so if you've got a good
deal and you're confident maybe get a
management company to say yes it's good
maybe get if you need a refurb just show
the Builder quote so you've got third
party maybe a third-party investor to
look over the deal and to confirm it's
good then you can go to your angel
investor and say hey here's the deal
also be really specific in what you want
don't just say here's the deal what do
you think what do you want to do no
here's the deal and here is my proposal
bang bang bang don't pressure the angel
investor you want to say now look
there's a lot of people I could go to
and I want to put this up to you first
if it works for you awesome if it
doesn't work for you awesome so you
don't pressure them be comfor make sure
the deals good have third-party credible
reputable people backing up the deal and
then make an offer that's what I'll say
good luck my friend if it comes off let
me know I want to hear the story okay
SM says hi Samuel could you do an
interview with Jim Holly burn that would
be really interesting I know Jim I've
actually I've met him a few times
listen if you want me to do an interview
of anybody a lot of people say to me
Samuel can you interview Graham Stefon
can you interview Jim Hobart can you
interview this that the other youtuber
star property investor business person
Henry used to tell them just tell them
if you want me to interview Jim how'd it
go and tell him just go I'm sure he's
got YouTube videos maybe he hasn't
actually but just email it go on its
website and just say can you please go
on Samuels YouTube channel I will
interview pretty much anybody I don't
care who they are as long as they're
going to be giving value to my audience
I don't care if they've got a big
following of small file
I don't care if they're an expert or a
failure
I don't care all I care about is that
they'll be giving value and good content
to my followers so if you want them on
my channel just tell them stop like
spamming the heck out of them saying get
on Sami all these YouTube channel and
I'll have Jim on Jim's cool I know Jim
Jim it's a court like tell him anything
if he wants to come on my channel he can
ask me and then ah book him on respect
okay Beth girls I tell you I found a
number of read to rent HMOs and
landlords are very keen on the idea but
what do I need to insure them I'm
completely legit okay Beth you don't
need to convince them you're legit if
you think I to convince them that I'm
legit because they're not going to think
I'm legit then they're not gonna think
you're legit and you're gonna need to
convince them to be legit but if you are
legit just just at legit just be normal
David think about it it's if I were
thinking this person's gonna be thinking
that home crazy and you take someone
bother I'm not crazy what are they gonna
think they're gonna think this dude's
crazy because he just told me he's not
crazy it's like people that always
youtubers that always say I'm authentic
I'm authentic it's like just be
authentic don't keep telling me how
authentic you are because then it makes
me wonder if you're not authentic and in
the same way if I'm doing business with
landlords I'm not gonna be saying this
she's gonna [ __ ] by the way you know
regimental real thing
I'm legit you know just relax just relax
you're legit you don't have to to try
and persuade anyone that you're legit
just offer a good deal or offer the land
a lot a good deal and then if the
landlord says it's a good deal but you
legit then tell him you cadential then
tell him but don't go in there thinking
I got a persuading that I'm legit that's
that's my advice Bob wish it were the
best let me know how you get on okay
last one Erin Herat says I've been
trying to find a good rent to rent or
loi lease option agreement property I'm
finding loads which could be good deals
but the problem is getting hold of the
landlord any advice on how to get hold
of the my lord all right so you're
finding loads but you can't get hold of
the landlord where are you filing loads
are you just driving through the streets
thinking that would be a good house and
you want to get harder than landlord
are you going on Rightmove where are you
finding them listen if I see a house I
Drive by a house and I think that's a
good
you know and I don't want to get in I'll
go on land registry pay three pounds and
I'll get the details of the landlord
I'll get all the information I need for
three pounds if I'm a right move you can
find the address just just zoom in and
look at the door number or then there
are ways on the crash course we do it
live so if you know if you don't meet
your crash course get on the crash
course but generally speaking for rent
to rents and Lease Option agreements I
find them on places like gum tree on
spare room on open rounds the landlord's
details are there if someone's
advertising their property to sell or to
rent their advertising themselves their
number will be on the on their so if
you'll finally get on these websites I
could within the space of 20 minutes I
could find over a hundred contact
details for direct landlords I know I
just I just constructed gum tree and
Sparrow and open it I could [ __ ] the
numbers and then I could phone them up
Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom and guess
what probably about ten of them would be
like Nana Nana I'm not interested and
then one of them would be like okay this
could work and then I jump on the phone
or do a viewing and then that one would
fall through and then I have to phone
another ten I get another ten rejections
and then I get another one
they'll be interested and then I got a
deal so scale combined with activity
combined we've just picked up the cursor
I don't know if that answered your
question I hope you did my seminars are
not seminars okay if you come to a
property investors crash course or any
of my training programs it's a do winner
so I don't get down we'll do it in fact
I'm going to put a link in the
description to the property investors
crash course and those people say Samuel
the crash course is too far it's so far
people come from Australia come from
Australia so don't be stopped - the very
first hurdle because if you're stopped
by three hour car journey oh man you're
we also stop by those tiny rejections
that you get give a like I called three
people and they said no this doesn't
work and then you're probably then
you'll probably start trolling my Egypt
it doesn't work it doesn't work just put
in the activity man like you've got the
content you've got the information put
in the activity get in the right
environment I love seeing you guys
succeed
I know that's why you're here that's why
you're on my channel so listen let me
ask you a favor if you enjoy my YouTube
videos if they're helpful please do
smash the like burn also subscribe
turn the notifications on if you want me
to answer your question comment below
and I will be doing a video next week on
Sunday at 7 p.m. and I'll be answering
your questions as many as I possibly can
thanks so much for watching
also the crash course if you want to
book on the crash course I'll leave a
link did you see that happen do you know
what that why that's there because you
need to click it use your book on it
right now go ahead go ahead go ahead I
hope to see you there god bless peace
out
[Music]